Sadness, loneliness and anxiety are normal
feelings that everyone has experienced.
These feelings can be triggered by specific
events, like the loss of a loved one or a
humiliating work experience.
But when our dark emotional state begins to
cause physical symptoms and lasts for long
periods of time, it can dramatically affect
our everyday behavior and inhibit us from
leading normal healthy lives.
Despite the social stigma associated with
it, major depressive disorder is surprisingly
common.
Studies show that 13% of the global population
will suffer from depression at some point
in their lives.
And even the World Health Organization considers
depression to be a major factor in diseases
of all types.
Despite depression being seemingly so commonplace,
the causes of depression and the different
factors that make it more likely to occur
are often misunderstood.
So, what types of thought processes lead more
easily to depressive states and what makes
some people more likely than others to suffer
from chronic depression?
In a landmark 1992 study, Rose and Abramson
established a clear link between three pessimistic
tendencies, also called negative inferential
styles and chronic depression.
Number one: Cause.
The first occurs when an individual blames
global causes for negative life events instead
of specific causes.
Someone who makes these types of attributions
will look at a negative event as caused by
something that cannot be changed by them and
extends across all areas of their life instead
of addressing the specifics of the situation
and looking to move forward from it in a positive
way.
At the same time, they also assume that their
successes are one-off situations that are
lucky or coincidental and not a result of
their own effort and behavior.
Number 2: Consequence.
Even if someone does not assume that they
are the main unchanging cause of negative
events in their life, they may still have
trouble seeing how a negative situation could
turn out positively.
People with this outlook on life see the worst
in every situation and assume the worst possible
outcomes.
Even though they might not blame themselves
for a particular event, they tell themselves
that there's no way to recover from it, believing
that they will forever be dealing with the
consequences of the negative situation.
Number 3: Self-image.
Individuals with this third tendency regularly
compare themselves with others who are performing
better than them in a certain task.
Because they view themselves so negatively
and believe that they are the cause of every
negative life event, they cannot see a way
forward from their current situation.
They see themselves as the root cause of every
issue and so feel a deep sense of hopelessness.
Although there are many different factors
which contribute to chronic depression, these
negative attribution styles always play a
major role.
Helping individuals who suffer from depression
to seek therapy focused on developing more
positive ways of thinking, building a strong
self-image and better understanding the root
causes of their emotions and how to constructively
deal with them is an essential part of treatment.
As with most illness, the deep shame that
accompanies depression can be paralyzing.
Please help end the stigma associated with
depression and other mental illnesses by coming
forward to speak about your own struggles,
encouraging others to come forward and always
being willing to listen without judgment.